all right there's this website called
bring fido it's a travel website where
you can bring your doggies
do you take them to hotels and stuff
check out the best
halloween costumes that is so cool
fruit loops these are great this is oh
my goodness
is that a um flower i guess it's a
flower but it's like the
dog-eating plant no you know what i mean
the music
the musical at the plants picture show
the hair and the puffy puppy outfit
um aviator aviator okay
oh it's black panther oh it looked like
he had oh i see the black panther
costume now at first i thought it was an
aviator costume
all right who's this that's a lion
oh my gosh it doesn't look so scary on
that cute little guy
oh look at these three okay with the
glasses
how cute yikes we're too blind to be
oh oh my goodness a rocket how could you
cute
oh my goodness you know if you can get
your dog to put these on
keep it on for long enough take a
picture you've already won halloween
yeah because that's a big enough
achievement
yeah that's the challenge right yeah
good luck with that
yeah like the pope
alex do you have plans for bodhi for his
uh costume
bobo was supposed to wear the shark yeah
the shark thing right right
so charlotte sent charlotte our pet
expert sent the shark costume you
weren't here honey
she sent me a human adult sized one oh
no i was here did you see this yeah
oh okay so it's a bit much so have you
ever put it on body yet
well no okay i have not
i don't think i think body would rip it
up so i don't know what bodhi is going
to be yet
you guys well if you're watching at home
send us pictures of your dog your cat
your gerbil whatever the case may be
your snake
in its own halloween costume